what does that work yeah hey look it
welcome to this video let's play the
hourly super blitz arena and I'm late
joining think fifteen minutes into the
tournament but we have seen that
sometimes you can catch up 17 minutes
actually okay
anyway I'm getting paired I don't know
should I observe every game I could be
tricky I should get a game by the way
otherwise it won't work okay
I basically have to treat it as a board
game looks a little bit wood I will take
a sniff it looks a little bit like a
snake venom only that it's not such a
terrible thing
it's not great the snake but you have
tons of tricky ideas and here we go a
ticking h2 formate just ticking we
should take h3 now is the front that's a
big issue hi
the reCAPTCHA yeah I'm just writing in
to take on a ch3 queen f1 maybe with his
material down for nothing much
96 would have been interesting for him I
think I still want to take on h3 here
now I will do it I just wanted to make
sure he's not meeting me - there why
it's not made but uh 970 could have
taken if I don't like Bishop f5 and
there is no mate that's a shame quicker
three now it's also a threat maybe I
should have thought about it for the
moment yeah but it's enough air
threatening f1 Queen okay so first
victory in which I need quick wins maybe
I will go efore with white and hope for
some quick knockouts
typical famous last words
okay what I definitely need is getting
paired I play green so similar is kind
of weird I could have taken d6 red okay
this is not
this is not bad either no no quit right
place
not with that bad King position you want
to keep the coins on the board you
should be successful idea okay and fy5
will be difficult for her to play
against let's know which it's made funny
mate okay so I was a quick one
let's get pair too quickly come on again
up the 21st please okay that's very
sporty yeah this is this is equal
unfortunately but okay very equal issue
actually maybe black is better here it's
a little bit easier for him but so
Manuel no it's okay
I think it's okay the default is not
doing that much and that's a good move
95 okay here hey there again t3m nair
didn't play that one fi this probably is
the gear headlights e5 though no wasn't
this idea maybe 95
coming now okay prevent it that you fall
if attacked cannot cover it i think
still looks a little bit shaky this
position my king but this is really not
inspiring or that much confidence that's
no good take you okay well if slightly
shaky somehow it fell down
okay i'm just six power points behind
the first place better 2004 very likely
how that you would play the open
Sicilian after the first couple of moves
maybe you will take ok at least I'm
getting the bishop pair even though my
whole development is like a costly play
non-existent ok I will grab that it's
not a big big issue 35 the cigarettes a
good move 90 X now no didn't do it still
not so easy
well if he takes and I manage we should
be six somehow I'm ok but it doesn't
look like it there well play gamer white
opening was a bit weird but she played
well afterwards so it's good strange it
should be six maybe I should have played
yeah I should have played ball there
should be six but I will we'll get some
attacking ideas going on with f3 here so
much body reacting on that whoa
that is the universe h4 gauge forget for
schnapps not really is reacting to
anything here now I'm making next move
h4 look at four would have been flashy
if it takes Queen g4 to f1 check kicking
one Bishop takes the f4 and I'm winning
I think but it didn't happen
yeah no yeah come on it's my next move
well I can check the text messages and
stuff hi okay
so third place just five points behind
better and usually you catch up pretty
quickly if you can preserve successfully
a couple of games Ling needle here we go
that's a pretty good line that I
recently checked like it's um oftentimes
not really prepared for this kind of
game and it gets a position like that
which is not that great
okay um what's going on here
well he's attacking me five which is a
bit of a nuisance maybe I have to do
this after me keep in mind that I'm
deserting him this is not ideal of
course can you forgive me game
my advances the cat checks too early I'm
still quite okay yeah I think the only
thing that is not so nice is that I have
spent pretty much time already and with
them buzzer King can be tricky but mmm
okay um night at 6:58 I have 96
this is not made on situa well I mean I
can do that there's nothing particularly
wrong with it look see towards just one
check and now ready for robot I probably
didn't have my chance to be honest 96 is
a tricky way two defenders didn't make
my life difficult it could have been a
lot to again no background mate please
and I recognized after playing a 4/4 the
back frame method he didn't even
threatened on f1 so that was a CLE
straight forward win this guy is scoring
well yeah I mean had a bad start but
then got into stride so game oh ok ok
and he actually g4 is good
really to h5 now maybe maybe now he has
to react
yes I'm really nice position avoid
having really nice control down Europe
cannot be in Cairo as t6 is hanging oh I
didn't think about this at all well
maybe you can just take it I already see
this as a big threat yeah the corn on e3
is not bad
it covers f4 and I'm out 495 anyway
should chief form it's not so easy
figure out how I'm going to break
through he takes a long time we set a
connection a shoe or something I can see
that somewhere I don't know okay
I don't think that this is all that
great maybe you can take on a to
actually and claim that b2 is not
possible to cover unlucky I can't
let's take this
- really lucky break you from black
chick I can go all the way here and
that's made immediately no our what the
heck I wanted to take on c4
well that was silly you had a heavy
totally winning position out of the
opening and then preen a fire somehow
and have to play quickly very strange
you have the Queen takes H 2 a 2 there
is no real defense anyway doesn't really
matter I think let's play the snake
belief around to irritate people it is
somewhat weird but tell me it's not a
bad opening if you have this is a little
time anyone job have some quick moves
that you can play it is a bit strange
and for with teaching this
okay
the snake bit only gets a lot better
when you are gifted an extra piece I try
c4b should be 6 and n 9f 5 mm yeah I
know H for it like it's written on d3
and a threatening Bishop e6 which it
might overlook okay so let's take this
first and down you know I'm two pieces
up and I will actually win the book what
is that say the exchange
here we go you take this as well
I can start to finish this off cakes
will be 194 Queen age for something like
that should want quite quickly let's
assume you don't see a direct maiden so
let's do something simple
yes is easier to attack with their many
extra pieces okay so where's the maid
here's the mate okay so second place
yeah but Edie lost that was a bit just
it was a bit annoying so five points
behind yeah it keeps winning aim them
I'm definitely need to get paired
quicker dearly died lie whatever had a
headache would start him but then all he
had to pause keep forgetting what is
correct against that ninety six stuff so
ninety-six stuff not this but I care to
just to make moves
and the night 1896 there in this in this
line but not snow sure okay so when I
don't I don't have really great square
for the Queen
let me to type now let's not good that's
a really really bad position for one for
one minute chest basically because of
the unsecured Queen position it's
objectively worse already but it is some
yeah it's just not easy to play this
stuff
rip this pawn which it takes a 5s is on
the agenda cannot do much about it more
group takes I don't know I'm happy if
I'm somehow surviving this I can just
take p6 on your ticket yeah
very simple and I let always hate it if
you play so terribly that that you get
make it so simple for the opponent that
he doesn't have to show anything for the
point yeah then opening that opening
result I mean it's not playing as well
but good enough but good enough
unfortunately
we'll have a funny idea there's a
meeting truck here with Bishop before
threatening to take now on f1 that's a
funny trick and then go d1 like to let
go is actually pretty neat one and now
it doesn't move outcome yeah I like the
trick but it doesn't work
and now I can take the aid that's not
good so on now probably the heck is not
the best opening for this kind of
scenario we you just have to sort too
many concrete problems them with your
green running all the players head was
not that most knowledge a good position
to play in and what is essentially a
bullet game Freeman that is okay with
this position with one minute block not
easy
okay now that looks kind of nice him
irritating him here and it was only way
for him to save it but it works
yeah hey with the C file and it's not
something terrible story
grab it
why not take a corner and basically
beccx move oh he takes it gives away the
queen
so interesting can try and clean you one
from eight yeah it's still late he takes
it okay that's good quick may down are
better also lost a game so I'm just two
points behind come on ah that is better
okay so I'm probably no berserk this
time let's just beat the guy now
shouldn't pre move the same Neji for
well not the greatest move but it is
some very good you see if you premium at
C 3 and lambda lambda stuff h3 no Bishop
g4 yeah this is a well-known position
type that is always very slightly more
comfortable for white but it is nothing
terrible for black quite quite clearly
the reason why there's a bit more
comfortable is that the position is
completely closed and blacks bishops
don't do all that much
okay now I'm trading this and he has
weakened the dark squares quite a bit
with a six surprisingly ie6 is a pretty
terrible move so chicken it's already
difficult Jim McKean cannot go to your
seven it's checkmate - checkmate
okay just two points unfortunately well
at least he didn't score my losses here
that cost me so many points or the other
ones don't really do much okay come on
twelve minutes it should be possible to
catch this guy we have just seen that he
can lose games who bowler very hydrated
so probably no berserk okay let's see I
can also take out of this one it's rare
but not a bad move t5 he already do this
is also my barriers and this is a looks
a bit like Hedgehog
[Music]
make easy to say it well young Saudi
fall is going back to see to a I don't
take five unfortunately young let's see
a leave an exciting this pollution so he
allows me to do that assess this is
actually good news Queen on d6 is not
badly placed and sometimes have to ship
c5 you create those kind of things maybe
he tries to put the Queen unto p1 and
then playing with 95 ideas really and
that is a really weird self in so you
only takes all my stuff but I don't mind
that
- so we'll take this no probably into
chick 90m 495 that's quite uncomfortable
for white it doesn't seem like if things
is just any dangerous is dangerous I
think it is
what is this reply actually 92 it looks
very weird maybe I have books a tool
that as well IAM i'm going for
full-scale invasion this and I'm taking
it to madness is actually strong first
Queen f3 Queen f3 yes this is very nice
Queen f3 yes
it's meat it's kind of clear there
should be something with all the active
pieces but Wow
and I have actually overtaken a better
forget additional points for Queen f3
unfortunately the computer doesn't give
you bonus points for nice and good fit
okay even if I'm finishing on second
place that was a culture good one
what's now again this line this is a
interesting variation we're really an
interesting variation where you give in
the technical place no matter where you
where you go from the good development
give up the bishop pair but you get
extremely good development and also good
control over dark squares as we see here
I mean he places a little bit weird
giving me everything look T files maybe
a move now that's maybe a move no
okay I could have taken a six not really
only six this is better for for better
control you can go hoop defy again but I
think I'm just better after the caption
but now just bring the king of it's just
a better ending yeah I can take it down
Media search should have prevented that
now that I think about it I didn't
bezerk him okay that is a reasonably
high way to play a bit but so could have
done it yeah yeah and this is going here
this is getting very very close door
chess has also scored pretty well yeah
this is some help some a little bit but
I don't think it out in the game will be
enough to draw still annoying this
position public I don't get three
unfortunately I wanted to go to h5 it's
actually true
but we'll defendant you defendant is
quite well it was a pretty pretty bad
position you managed to sort of hold six
looking at for this Knight takes c6 so
we cannot take their check here yeah I'm
still not still not winning
[Music]
496 takers ah I got completely blind at
that point
Oh No oh that's totally ridiculous
I completely blundered upon I know I
asked you this know yeah I know black is
is even winning this freaking game this
is unbelievable
he sits drawing moving on time maybe not
winning this is terrible I am come on at
that very nice game against border and
it's pretty still pretty terrible not to
win it the whole thing I mean that last
game was just completely winning out of
the opening of solution alright anyway
so I think it was not good stuff and
hope I enjoyable to watch one very nice
interference border which compensates
for for something